one is with us in Orlando hey one
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show better
than I deserve what's up um so I
invested 80,000 in stock and I was down
to ten thousand good lord
take it out and yeah I know I made my
own recession should I take it out and
take it as a loss Oh keep the stock and
hope for the best
well I mean we don't buy it we don't
make the decision based on how about a
bloodbath we've already taken we asked
what will the ten thousand do going
forward do you think it's going to come
back to eighty do you have any reason to
believe that yeah I think it's gonna go
up because it went down to sixty cents
and it went up to a dollar and thirty
cents but I got in at three dollars so
my question is um if you had ten
thousand dollars in your hand today
would you invest it into this stock
thinking it was gonna go up honestly if
I would say you know why if I take it
out if I take out the money I think I
would just use it as a cushion no
standing you're misunderstand me the way
you make the decision is what do you
think the future is not how bad the past
hurts the past hurts really don't make
the decision I mean if you think the
path if you think the future is hey
there sir I feel good about this I think
the things coming back to eighty I think
it's going back three dollars and three
dollars down to one dollar is not 80
down to ten wait a minute that math
doesn't work I believe it's gonna go up
by the grace of God I believe so
well God's grace covers a lot of stuff
usually stock price isn't on the list I
mean that's just you're praying that's
good yeah I don't blame you man you took
a bath okay so wait a minute it would
have had to go down 90% you would had to
go for $3 to 30 cents for it to go from
80 to 10
it was like three dollars and change and
then it went down to sixty cents and now
it's about 93 cents oh okay so they want
it to be one per it should be one-third
of what it was then yeah so it shouldn't
be eighty down to ten it would be eighty
down to about 25 Wow
what's your stock do you think it's
worth twenty-five I mean ninety three
said 93 cents what's it worth $10,000
it's a little bit over ten thousand it's
at like 11,000 okay then some of your
other numbers are broken do you see what
I'm doing yeah
if three dollars turns into a dollar
that's a seventy that's a 67 percent
loss that is not a ninety percent loss
and so we go from 80 to 25 you wouldn't
go from 80 to 10 so something on your
numbers is wrong but you can go back and
visit that the way you answer your
question of whether to stay in it is do
you think the tens going to go back up
quickly like by Christmas where do you
think this is going to be a year in four
months by Christmas where do you think
this is going to be I mean I so I'm
hoping for the best that's not a good
answer okay hoping get you'll turn into
10,000 into 1,000 so you need to have a
good case in your mind it says 10,000 is
gonna go to 30 or to whatever by
Christmas or I just think this thing is
a squirrel and I don't know what it's
gonna run up the trigger down the tree
and so in that case you get out and you
take you know and you take your lick and
you never do this crap again leverage in
other areas like I have a company that I
just started called blessed ourselves
and I'm just I have inventory and I
created my own jobs I sell air
fresheners so I have money that I can
make money that can pay my bills you can
do that any
now you don't need the money to pay your
bills but the question is what's the
best use of this 10,000 is it going to
come back up or is it or we don't know
what it's going to do it's just a
squirrel and so if you if you can if you
think it's just a squirrel then get out
of the nut business man I mean you're
getting killed you know so but if you
have some knowledge of this company and
that caused you to be in there in the
first place that says that this thing
should go up it's ridiculous that it's
just low and you want to have a little
patience with it I'm not gonna kill you
for that